So this next story is, um, ironic, funny and
sad.
At the same time, a Texas teacher was fired
for trying to report undocumented students
to the president of the United States.
Um, before I read her tweets and let me read
the quote from NBC News.
Uh, to give you the background quote, uh,
the Fort Worth Independent School district
unanimously voted eight to zero to terminate
the employment of Georgia Clark and a special
meeting Tuesday Clark, an English teacher
at Carter Riverside high school tweeted that
the school she worked for had been taken over
by illegal students from Mexico that Trump
was elected on the promise that a wall will
be built to protect our borders and tweeted
multiple statements referencing illegals,
but it kits better or worse depending on how
you view the story.
She said, quote, uh, she was suspended, or
the article rather said quote, she was suspended
in 2013 after she allegedly referred to a
group of students as little Mexico and another
student as white bread.
Clark is also under investigation for a complaint
that she allegedly told a student to quote,
show me your papers.
You are illegal after the student asks permission
to go to the bathroom.
Um, according to the district documents, Clark
told an investigator she thought the tweets
were a direct message to president Trump and
didn't know they were public.
That's the part that is so delicious.
The fact that she so smart with her bigotry
that she didn't even know how to use the system
that ended up leading to her firing now.
And you can, well, you could quibble over
whether or not she should have lost her job
over this, uh, over the tweets.
But you can't really, uh, a quibble over whether
or not she should have been in the classroom
in the first place.
Like looking at her history, there's, there's
really no reason that this type of person
should be in a classroom anywhere in this
country, uh, not only because of her bigotry,
but also because of her level of ignorance.
I mean, there's a level of ignorance here
that really screams out.
I not qualified to teach anybody, uh, but
she found out the hard way.
I want to pull up the tweets on your screen
so that you could see, uh, what she said.
It's a series of tweets that she sent clearly
identifying herself, trying earnestly to report,
uh, the undocu quote unquote undocumented
students.
Um, then it didn't really work out too well
for her.
This is what she said on back in May.
She said, quote, Mr President, Fort Worth
Independent School district is loaded with
illegal students from Mexico.
Uh, Carter Riverside high school has been
taken over by them.
Drug dealers are on our campus and nothing
was done to them.
When drug dogs found the evidence.
Donald Trump, could you please remind the
Democrats that a majority of the people elected,
you know, they didn't, but I digress.
Um, could you please remind the Democrats
that a majority of the people elected you
on the promise that a wall would be built
to protect our borders?
Just how many of us voted for you?
Shouldn't we?
The people count for something.
I, I love, uh, I'm sorry, pet cut back to
me.
I love, I love how she's like really making
an earnest plea here.
I don't even know if the rest of the tweets
are worth reading.
I just want to pause and talk about how genuine
this woman is with her bigotry.
Like that last line.
Oh No, actually you do have to show these
tweets.
I'm sorry.
It gets better.
She said in that last line, shouldn't we?
The people count for something.
And then the next tweet is, my prayers were
answered.
Drain that swamp.
And the sooner the better.
I mean, folks, I, I don't like to revel in,
in people's destruction, but man, the irony
that the it is, is just how are you so genuine
about being, watch my mouth.
I'm on David's show, a jerk, a bigot, like
from the depths of our heart.
She really is pouring out to what she thought
was a direct message to the president, but
public on Twitter and she's genuinely pouring
out her bigger tree.
I'm sorry, I want me to be so dramatic, but
that's really something, it reminds me of
the story.
I don't know if it's been covered.
I, maybe I should cover it or I'll just mention
it here.
Uh, the story of the little seven year old
boy in Texas who raised $22,000 to a, to help
Donald Trump build a wall.
And he raised it by selling hot chocolate
in Texas in June.
And somebody tweeted on Twitter, they said,
you've got to be one hell of a racist to buy
hot chocolate in June in Texas.
I mean, I'm laughing, but we maybe should,
we should be crying because look at the level
of commitment that these morons have to their
bigotry.
She's so committed.
And so, no, she was genuine and so committed.
But, but, but the, but the story of the, of
the, of the hot chocolate is really about
the commitment where you're willing to go
out there and drink hot chocolate in a hundred
degree weather in Texas.
These people are so dedicated to their, and,
and, and, and I really drive that point home
because there's no, there's no working with
them, man.
There's, there's no reaching across the aisle
to them.
I know, I know.
I don't, I'm not sure where David stands on
that, so I can't really say whether David
thinks we should.
Uh, reach across the aisle or not.
I got it.
Maybe I'll go watch them as videos, but for
me, in my house, you know, when somebody is
so dedicated to their bigotry that they're
willing to drink hot chocolate in Texas at
a hundred degree weather, uh, to help build
the wall, they, there's really no reasoning
with them.
There's no, there's no trying to, uh, explain
something and win them over.
Um, it, it just becomes an exercise in futility,
uh, in, in my best estimation.
So this woman was fired.
Um, I, I'm sorry for laughing so much at her
for being fired.
Uh, not so much in her for being fired, but
boot because of the sincerity of her bigotry.
Um, I, I've never seen, it's like, it's like
as hard as we fight, uh, as genuine as we
fight to help liberate people and help set
them free and help get the boot of the oppressor
off their neck as hard as we fight for that.
And as dedicated as we are to that, and as
genuine as we are about that, they're equally
as genuine,
their bigotry towards those people.